Welcome to this education session.
This session is actually, really, we want to use it
to discuss a slightly different topic instead of the
signaling transaction transmitted by biochemical
signal. We're going to focus on mechanical signal in tumor
development, progression, metastasis, and also
therapy resistance. And
this is one of the introduction slides I prepared.
As we all know that when tumor are initiated and then
they spread, there's variety of force that the
tumor cell experience. The extracellular matrix
exert force to the tumor cells. There's a compression force.
There are also topological differences.
And when the tumor cells get out of the circulation and get into
the circulation, there's also shear force.
So during this very complex journey, when the primary
tumor form and then become metastatic and arrive in a
different organ, there's variety of physical forces
that actually, I think we will present data to
show that they actually play quite critical role in
modulate this event. So we will have three speakers.
We are using different system, different cancer type, different
model system, trying to address this question.
So
we will have our first speaker, Dr.
Sanjay Kumar from
UC
Berkeley. Sorry, I don't know how to turn this on.
Yeah.
Oh, start.
Oh, here. There we go. There it is.
Okay.
Good. Thank you very much, Jing, for organizing this wonderful session.
Thanks all of you for coming. So today I'll say a few words
about our work over the last two decades, really, but especially the last four or
five years in trying to use biomaterial models to
study the process of glioblastoma invasion with steps towards
identifying potentially therapeutically actionable targets and incorporate
components of the stromal microenvironment.
So as I mentioned, our lab is primarily interested in this invasive brain tumor,
glioblastoma or GBM. And if you're not familiar with this, this is
not a tumor that you want to get diagnosed with.
It's the most common primary intracranial tumor and has a really
horrible clinical course in that median survival post-diagnosis
is only about a year to a year and a half, and that's assuming you get very
aggressive therapy, including surgical resection, radiation, and
chemotherapy. This series of MRs in the upper left
illustrates the clinical course of GBM.
This is what a newly diagnosed GBM might look like, this mass lesion here in the
right cerebral hemisphere. First-line treatment is surgical
resection, if for no other reason than to palliate,
typically coupled with radiation therapy and a chemotherapeutic
called temozolomide. Unfortunately, patients will return more
or less inevitably months later with recurrent tumor, as you can see with these
hyperintense lesions near the surgical cavity.
And then by 17 months, this is now a postmortem scan.
So what this is intended to illustrate, in part, is that this is a disease of cell
migration. Tumor cells have this uncommon ability to infiltrate brain
tissue, and this both drives disease progression and also fuels
chemoresistance, refractoriness to surgical
resection, and so forth. So there's much interest in trying to understand
how this invasion into the three-dimensional structure of
brain contributes to GBM pathophysiology.
There's also some evidence that invasion may contribute to chemoresistance at
various levels, and this has particularly become an issue for anti-angiogenic
therapy, which does a good job of reducing tumor mass but is
often accompanied by this invasive resistance phenomenon, where choked off
from
generating their own blood supply, tumor cells will invade towards a host blood
supply. And at the end of the day, there's very little survival benefit.
Now, what makes this disease
particularly challenging to model in vitro is that the architecture of the brain
is not only very important but also varies quite a lot depending on what part of
the tumor you're looking at. So classically, tumors are thought to invade
locally through the peritumoral microenvironment or the brain parenchyma,
which is very rich in a polysaccharide called hyaluronic acid.
And then tumor cells will often home towards structures, the so-called
structures of shear within the brain, including white matter tracts, as shown here,
and blood vessels, and will sometimes migrate very rapidly along those
structures.
So I'm going to talk about the peritumoral portion of this today, our efforts to
try to model this hyaluronic acid-rich portion of brain matrix.
So, as I mentioned, the key player here in this portion of brain matrix is this
sugar, hyaluronic acid, which not only organizes
extracellular matrix proteins like the tenascins into a three-dimensional structure
but also can directly engage receptors on the cell surface, most notably
CD44. And as you may know, CD44 is more than just sort of a
staple that holds cells to HA. It is itself also a fairly potent
activator of oncogenic signaling, as well as a marker of tumor stem
cells. So much of what we know about hyaluronic acid biology comes
from our colleagues in the musculoskeletal field because this is also a very
important component of cartilage.
So you can purchase hyaluronic acid off the shelf, but if you put it into solution,
you won't get a three-dimensional hydrogel that you can then implant cells into.
You have to do a little bit of chemistry.
And fortunately, there are some handles on the hyaluronic acid backbone that are
amenable to that, including this hydroxyl group here, which we tend to focus
on. So what we typically do is we'll convert the hydroxyl group into a
methacrylate group, which is an acceptor for a type of chemistry called Michael
addition chemistry, which proceeds fairly rapidly under physiologic conditions.
And the story with this chemistry is that essentially anything with a thiol will
rapidly form a covalent bond with these methacrylate groups.
So we can do things like attach short adhesion peptides that ligate integrins as
long as they contain cysteines, and we can also cross-link the HA into a
3D gel using a di-cysteine molecule, something as simple as
DTT.Or something as more complex or nuanced,
such as a peptide that has two cysteines, where the peptide itself can be
cleaved by cell-derived matrix metalloproteases.
So we've been working with these materials for a number of years, deployed them as
2D surfaces, 3D gels, as microgels for 3D printing, and here are some of
our publications in the area. This has been a wonderful platform
for us to study fundamental aspects of interactions between tumor cells and HA.
And I won't go into this paper in great detail.
This is the work of Kayla Wolf, a former graduate student in the lab, who's now
a faculty member at Cornell in biomedical engineering.
And long story short, she discovered a mechanism where tumor cells engage
HA through structures called microtentacles, similar to what one finds on
circulating tumor cells. And she was able to elucidate this molecular
complex that provides a mechanism both for attachment to HA and
transmission of forces.
And this is one of several studies we've undertaken
where we've done deep dives into understanding how tumor cells engage
HA.
And they've been wonderful for mechanistic discovery, but they do have a number of
limitations. The first is these platforms tend to be fairly limited in
scale. So great for things like spheroid invasion studies, where you have
hundreds of thousands of cells
and are perturbing one or a handful of candidates.
But if one is trying to do things like omics analysis or screening where you need
to have coverage, the cell numbers aren't really great enough to support that.
Additionally, because of this inability to cast a wide net, data from
these materials can be difficult to benchmark against patient data, where
almost universally with GBM, every newly diagnosed patient or tumor is
sequenced, increasingly with single-cell sequencing.
I mentioned earlier that these tumors are quite heterogeneous,
particularly with respect to invasion.
So if we were to take one of these preparations, homogenize the whole thing, and
take a measurement, we might lose information associated with the most invasive
cells, which is where the targets are likely to be.
So some years ago, we decided to retool our systems and ask if we might be able to
develop a 3D HA-based invasion platform for comparative systems-level
analysis of invasive versus non-invasive cells.
And the goal here is to try to identify biomarkers of invasive cells, and more
ambitiously, identify therapeutic targets that could be acted
upon. So I'll tell you about the work of Erin Aikens, a former grad student
in the lab, who deployed our HA matrices into a device format where
we could essentially load millions of cells into very large channels
embedded within HA and watch the tumor cells invade, literally over the
course of a month to a month and a half.
And so we can watch this whole invasion process occur under the microscope,
the so-called tumor in a dish. But where this is really powerful is that we can
physically dissect out different regions of the tumor and subject them to
comparative analysis. And in particular, we look at the core of the region
of the tumor shown here,
and then the invasive rim shown here.
And where this is really powerful is we can now directly compare these data against
data from patients. And so this work has been done in collaboration with Manish
Aghi, a neurosurgeon scientist at UCSF, who can do
site-directed biopsies from patient GBMs in his operating
room. So, I'm skipping over a lot of preliminaries here, but this is
nanoString analysis of
the invasive rim of a patient GBM now versus core GBM.
And this is worked-up sequencing data from our devices, essentially showing
invasive versus core. And we're under no illusion whatsoever that we can
recapitulate all of the nuances of a patient tumor with this very simple in vitro
system. But where we see matches in hits between patients and
our data, these are fertile ground for us to pursue.
So in looking for those matches, one of the first things we noticed was that
transcripts associated with reactive oxygen species signaling were greatly
enriched, both in our devices as well as in patient tumors.
And this work has all been published now for a couple of years, so I won't get into
the workup. But we elucidated what we think is a mechanism that
invading tumor cells use to manage high loads of
reactive oxygen species as they invade.
And it involves enhancement of a pathway called the transsulfuration
pathway, which is the cell's endogenous mechanism for synthesizing cysteine and
glutathione. And if we target that, either pharmacologically or
genetically, we can limit invasion.
More recently, another aspect of the tumor microenvironment we've been trying
to come to grips with in our model is the mechanics.
So brain tissue, like many other soft tissues within
the brain, are what we call viscoelastic.
So they're capable of both relaxing stresses as well as storing them.
And this has a number of implications, both for the bulk mechanics of brain tissue,
which needs to be very resistant to mechanical trauma,
but also to the sorts of stresses that cells feel as they migrate at the
microscale. Because in a stress-relaxing material, when a cell generates
force, that force will be dissipated to some degree over time.
And so that needs to be accounted for in the materials.
This is the work of Emily Carvalho, a former PhD student who's now doing a
postdoc in New York City at the new Sinai RPI Center for Bioengineering Precision
Medicine. This is a review that we wrote on this subject when we were first
starting to think about this problem.
So we became interested in asking how we might be able to incorporate viscoelastic
materials into our models. And Emily made the
recognition fairly early on that the brain offers a
natural way to think about modeling mechanical properties.
And in particular, normal brain tissue, as I mentioned, is very
viscoelastic, so it does a tremendous job at relaxing applied
stresses. And that's correlated with a
particular distribution of hyaluronic acid molecular
weights. So a normal brain matrix tends to have very, very high molecular weight
HA.
And to some extent, correlations have been developed between
tumor progression and HA molecular weight distribution.
And it's known that the HA in the vicinity of a tumor tends to be much
lower molecular weight, sort of raising this idea that the tumor cells might be
degrading the HA as they invade.So Emily
developed a set of materials, both with low molecular weight HA and
high molecular weight HA, and was able to develop
viscoelastic versions of high molecular weight HA, essentially by
making solutions of high molecular weight HA and very lightly cross-linking
them using one of these matrix metalloprotease degradable
peptides and attaching RGDs for integrin ligation.
And the idea here is that applied stresses are stored to some degree by these
crosslinks and dissipated by the fact that these are very flexible, floppy
polymer chains that can rearrange and move around as the cell applies
force.
So she developed a family of these materials, and importantly, developed
one that matched viscoelastic properties of brain tissue.
So these are our own measurements in an instrument called a
rheometer. So this formulation, H80, relaxes
80% of the stress that's thrown at it over some defined period of time,
and this matches very nicely the stress relaxation properties of brain tissue.
So the first thing that Emily did was to implant spheroids into these
materials and ask if the stress relaxation properties
changed the way that they invade. And she found very strikingly that
placing cells in these stress-relaxing materials, H80 versus L5, which is a
very elastic material, greatly speeds invasion.
And this is something that we see both in continuous cell culture models as
well as in patient-derived GSEs. So we see faster invasion.
We also see more cells escaping the spheroid as a function of time.
So we started to play around with the tools that are
available to us within these materials, in particular, including or
excluding RGD peptides for integrin ligation, as well as making
these crosslinks MMP degradable or not degradable.
And the one thing that really seemed to control in this expedited
invasion in the system was
integrin ligation. So if we
exclude the RGD peptides, these cells can no longer
use integrins to engage the matrix. They no longer invade faster.
But interestingly, if we make the crosslinker non-MMP degradable, they still
invade just as fast. So this property seems to be independent of MMP
degradation. I'll get back to that in a second.
So to get a closer look at the dynamics of invasion, Emily returned to our device
format, cultured cells in viscoelastic matrices in these
devices, and asked if she could gain some insight into how they invade.
And she noticed a couple of things that were very interesting.
The first is that the first few cells out of the device tend to look very, very
dendritic. And this is interesting in the abstract, but particularly
notable in light of intravital imaging that's been done.
And so this is the work of Frank Winkler, published in a number of incredible
papers over the last decade or so, where he's able to watch
tumor cells migrating in endogenous brain tissue.
And the morphologies that we see are very similar to what we see from these, what
we call leader cells.
But only the leader cells really look like this.
The cells that come out after the leader cells tend to follow almost single file
linearly right behind the leader cells.
So we describe this as a leader-follower-based invasion.
And so it's tempting to think that the leader cells are sort of paving a
way, creating a path within the matrix for the followers to follow.
But we already showed that this effect is not dependent at all on matrix
metalloprotease-based digestion, so how indeed might these leader cells be
digesting the matrix? And so we hypothesized the leaders might be digesting
the HA backbone itself to facilitate invasion using
enzymes that break down HA.
And so to test this, Emily did a number of studies where she
used broad-spectrum hyaluronidase inhibitors.
I'll show slides or images about that in a second.
Also imaged some of the hyal
isoforms, so hyaluronidase isoforms encoded within the human genome, and
interestingly found that leader cells leave a little trail of
HYAL2 right behind them as the followers follow.
So it's sort of consistent with this idea that almost like a trail of breadcrumbs,
except the breadcrumbs now are enzymes, are left behind digesting the HA and
enabling these follower cells to migrate much more efficiently.
And as I mentioned, if you throw broad-spectrum hyaluronidase inhibitors at the
cells, you break this leader-follower dynamic, and essentially all
cells are on their own. So every cell sort of becomes a leader, and as a result,
migration is much slower and less efficient.
You can really sort of see this HYAL trail idea in spheroid culture.
So this is now confocal imaging of spheroids invading viscoelastic matrices.
And you can see that leader cells leave almost like a comet tail
of HYAL2 behind them as they invade.
And you can sort of follow the path of followers as they move through the matrix,
and they do so much more efficiently because a path has been cleared.
Moreover, this HYAL-based digestion is associated with mechanical changes.
So without getting into too much detail, we developed a way
to dissect these devices so we could use atomic force
microscopy to mechanically measure viscoelastic properties at
different positions, essentially along the invasive front.
And the data that we found was sort of consistent with this idea that I introduced
earlier, that as tumor cells invade, they essentially chew up and
fluidize the hyaluronic acid-based matrix, and we see both reductions in
elasticity as well as increases in stress relaxation.
And to some degree, that's borne out by a similar analysis that we did
of mouse brain tumors. So taking cross-sections, doing
similar sorts of analyses. The two
parameters don't couple exactly
the same between the materials and the tumor cells.
But in very broad strokes, the idea is very much borne out.
And if you're interested in atomic force microscopy and some of the technical
details as to how to do these measurements, we published a paper just on the
methodology at the end of
2024.
So this is sort of our
model that we have in mind. The idea is that normal brain tissue is this
very viscoelastic, high molecular weight-dominated HA
matrix, and that as tumor cells make their way through the matrix, they
secrete hyaluronidases, which essentially locally
digest the HA matrix, thereby fluidizing it.And also creating a
path for followers to follow through.
And this is something that we typically don't see in these highly elastic, low
molecular rate matrices. This does raise the question as
to why viscoelastic matrices produce this behavior and purely
elastic matrices don't. Our leading hypothesis, that this has something to do with
the flexibility of the HA chains and their susceptibility to hyaluronidase
digestion, but we haven't
completely proven that just yet.
And so this work was described in this paper that came out about a year and a half
ago in "Advanced Materials," sort of describing both the material systems, the
imaging, the cell biology, and the mechanistic studies.
I'll just end by pointing you to some companion studies that our lab has
published that I won't have time to talk about, but are very much in the same
space. One question we've been very interested in is, how do
cells remodel the matrices that we put them in to facilitate invasion?
And so Jungua Cha, former post-doc in the lab, did shotgun
proteomics on tumor cells as they were invading HA, just to ask
what sorts of matrix proteins cells deposited, and
discovered that this kind of unusual form of collagen, collagen
VI, which is one of the microfibrillar collagens, is very heavily deposited
into the matrix prior to invasion, and it seems to play a role in organizing other
collagens to
speed the process of invasion. Some other work that Erin Aikens
did when she was a PhD student in the group was start to look at the paracrine
effects of tumor-associated macrophages.
And so in this paper, she discovered that
tumor-associated macrophages secrete a number of matricellular factors that help
to drive tumor invasion, including Biglycan H3, also
known as
TGF-beta-induced
protein.
We have also started to look at more broadly
the role of paracrine factors in driving invasion.
So Kwasi Amofa, a former graduate student in the lab, looked at effects
of TGF-beta-induced invasion. And then Dana Wilkins, a
current graduate student in the lab, in a first step towards studying
neuroglioma crosstalk within the system, showed that even tumor
cell-secreted glutamate is capable of driving invasion within these
systems. And so we're just at the beginning of starting to use this system to more
broadly incorporate components of the stromal compartment.
So I'll stop there. I'd like to thank the folks that did the work.
This is my lab in front of our building at UC Berkeley.
The work I told you about, a lot of it has been done in collaboration with Manish
Ahmi, neurosurgeon scientist at UCSF.
We're starting to work more with Kenny Yu at Sloan Kettering on tumor-associated
macrophages, and some collaborators involved with other work.
This is the current membership of the lab. These are our funding sources.
Thank you very much for your attention. Happy to take any questions.
Hi, Cathy O'Connor from the University of Kentucky.
Wonderful talk. I was wondering if you had considered the idea that
your hyaluronidases might actually be secreted into
microsomes. The patterning behind your leader
cells are very much in line with the patterning you'd see in
microsomes.
Yes, we have. So, I didn't get into the data at this
level of granularity, but it's not secreted as sort of a
continuous line. They do seem to be punctate behind the leader cells.
But I think we speculated in the discussion of that paper that those might be
exosomal, but
didn't feel comfortable enough to commit to that because we didn't do the
usual due diligence you would do. But if you ask me to guess, I'd say that's the
mechanism.
Yeah, there's some nice
staining mechanisms for microsomes if you're interested.
I have one other quick question.
My lab studies integrin alpha 6 beta 4, which is particularly high in
gliomas and glioblastomas. I was wondering, because you're working
with RGD peptides, which have nothing to do with laminin binding
integrins, have you considered looking at laminins and their
role in laminin binding integrins?
Oh, yeah. Absolutely. So, my
gestalt read is that the laminin mimetic peptides are not quite so
laminin mimetic relative to the fibronectin, vitronectin ones.
So, ICVAV and IGSR and so forth.
So, we've tried to do that but haven't
gotten as robust integrin mimetic
adhesion as we get with the RGDs.
I will defend RGD a little bit in the sense that there are some HA-associated
proteins that do have RGD sequences, and this factor that we
showed TAM secrete that drive invasion, Biglycan H3, has
an RGD domain in it. And we've taken that RGD domain, stapled it onto
our matrices, and it seemed to support adhesion and migration.
But I agree with you. I think it would be good to
be more broad.
Yeah, it would be interesting to see if your laminins are actually secreted into
your hydrogels, because
we find that the integrin can actually regulate the expression of its own
laminins.
Yeah.
Which is weird for an integrin to be able to do, but it may not need to be
added as the cells can make them themselves, so.
Yeah, now that you mention it, we're probably sitting on that data now.
The proteomics that we did would, to some extent, have the answer.
So, we will take a look.
Thank you.
Hi. Great talk. I had a question. So
in one of your data slides, you showed that
one leader cell kind of bifurcates it, right?
So I just had a couple questions. One, do you see all of your leader cells
bifurcating? And two, why?
Hmm.
Yeah, I don't know-- It's a very interesting pickup.
I don't know that we see every one strictly bifurcate like
that. I typically describe it as more of a dendritic type of morphology where there
are many
protrusions that are generated at the front of the cell, but with some
hierarchy, right? There's maybe a sort of mother protrusion and daughter
protrusions, but I don't know that it's always two or predominantly two.
Okay. Thank you.
Lovely talk. Thank you. Two questions.
So
thinking about the leader cells, is it always the
same cell that become the leader cell, or is that a somewhat stochastic
event that if you repeated this experiment 100 times, it will be 100
different cells that became leader cells?
And do you know what induces that sort of thing?
Yeah, that's a really good question. Thanks for asking that.
So the one experiment we have done is we've,
after harvesting the invasive fraction, taken those
cells, put them back into devices, done the same thing with the core.
And the simple interpretation seems to be that
every scenario is capable of generating leaders.
So it's not some permanent
modification that's made that confers that property.
I will point you, though to-- We haven't explored this all that much, but a
colleague, who is now at Rice, Cindy Reinhart-King, who works in breast cancer, has
found similar sorts of mechanisms there.
And she's elucidated these really elegant mechanisms where leader cells need a lot
of energy to become leaders. They eventually run out of energy, so they exhaust
their ATP stores, and then followers come up and become leaders while
the previous leaders are resting and catching up.
So-
Okay
... maybe there's something like that happening here, but I'd encourage you to take
a look at that work because it's very impressive.
Yeah. Thank you.
Oh, yes.
Hi.
Yes.
My name is Zoe. I'm a student at Heidelberg University and at Harvard
University, and I have a question about the tumor microenvironment.
Have you done any co-culturing with immune cells with your model, and how that
would impact the layering, for example?
Yes. Yes, we have. So that's
easier said than done. I think anyone that's done co-culture can
attest.
We've done one or two at a time, so tumor-associated macrophages,
endothelial cells.
So the first thing with the
tumor-associated macrophages we did was to actually do a co-culture, saw greater
invasion in that setting. And then to get some insight into whether
they actually need to be associated or whether it might be secreted factors, we did
the conditioned media experiment.
Conditioned media drove invasion just fine, so we stopped doing the co-cultures at
that point and just focused on the conditioned media.
But won't always be able to get away with that, especially for endothelial cells,
where cells do actually migrate along vessels.
So we've invested some time in trying to get that sort of system set up.
And then, sorry, I have a second question, is are you working just with spheroids,
or are you also working with patient-derived tissue material directly?
Yeah. So
that's been technically challenging to work with material that comes right out of
the operating room for a number of reasons.
So the material itself, there isn't that much of it.
At a big
brain cancer center like UCSF, there's a long line of people that want that
material, and then there's the question of getting it from OR to lab in one piece.
So, we've been, for that reason, heavy
proponents of the GSC systems, where
either from freshly derived samples or from banked sources,
get GSCs from patient tumors. They're characterized.
We know something about the clinical history of the tumor.
And it's a little bit more of a renewable resource, so that's what we've done
so far. But absolutely, if the patient materials were more available and scalable,
we'd love to use them more.
Thank you very much.
Maybe a follow-up question about the-
Yeah
... of the leader cell. So what's the signaling triggers the
secretion or the synthesis of the hyaluronidase?
The honest answer is we don't know.
Mm.
And that's a tough one to address because
this isn't a particularly defined medium at this point.
Mm.
So maybe if we start, of course, with neurobasal medium and some growth factors,
but this is after several days in culture.
The cells are secreting all kinds of cytokines and
matrix into the matrix. So it's tough to figure that out.
But
yeah, I'd love to talk offline if you have good strategies.
All right. Thank you.
All right. So now we switch a little bit, but still on
the idea of extracellular matrix force, how that regulate
tumor invasion and metastasis. And we're going to
switch the cancer type. My lab largely focus on breast
cancer. I apologize if you think it's a little bit not as
focused because there's a MAC to PC conversion issue.
But you can see that in this
system, that basically the different cell types in our body actually experience
very different physical environment, from the very soft brain and
lung and mammary gland to the very stiff like bone
and also where we culture our cells on the plastic dish.
During tumor progression, especially in breast cancer, there's about a
40, 50-fold increase of stiffness.
As we all know that most times breast tumor actually are diagnosed
or sensed because there's a hard lump in a very compliant tissue.
So you can actually measuring the tumor stiffness.
This is Valerie Weaver's group measuring the normal mammary
gland versus the invasive tumor in the same tissue.
You can see that unlike the normal mammary gland is really a
few hundred pascal, breast tumor actually largely about
2,000 to 4,000 pascal.
And you can also do indirect measurement to look at stiffness,
which is much easier, which is to look at using second
harmonic generation microscopy to look at the collagen fiber
curvature. Basically, you can see this is two breast tumor.
They're all stage three breast cancer, but this tumor shows very
curved collagen. This one shows very straight collagen, which you
already can sense this is a much stiffer tumor.
It turns out that this is our own work, but other people also
reported that when you have a stiff tumor, even if they're at
the same stage, actually is correlated with poor survival in breast
cancer patients. So the main question we have been trying to address in the
past almost 15 years since we started working in this field
isWhat from the ECM that transmit the signal
that drives this more invasive, more metastatic phenotype in
breast cancer?
So the way we're addressing this is also
started by using the 3D
system where, like
many in the mammary field, we can culture mammary cells, both
normal cells and tumor cells in Matrigel.
They will form our organoid, just like what you see here.
But the way we do it to integrate the mechanical
force into this system is to cross-link this
Matrigel with hydrogel. So hydrogel is actually the
most common one. We use both HA-based and also
polyacrylamide-based gel, where we can specifically tune the
hydrogel to become very soft, a few hundred
pascal, to very stiff, which mimicking breast tumor.
That's usually about 1,000 pascal.
And from now on, all the tumors cell
type I'm going to talk about are triple negative.
So basically, the reason is that because triple negative breast
cancer have this enriched basal subtype gene signature.
It has a EMT actually gene signature.
This is one of the area my lab has been focusing on.
And so this is one we cultured. So we use both
human mouse triple negative. We also use PDX, but here
I'm only going to show you one line, but most of them behave
the same in the system. You can see when we culture
the cells in the soft stiffness, you can see that
the organoid polarized, have E-cadherin, and has a
polarized structure. But when you culture them in a
stiff condition, you can see this phenotype, we call them
epithelial-mesenchymal transition.
The cell lose polarity, loosening its junctions, started to
express mesenchymal marker. What really
impressed us is that we actually treated the culture with
TGF-beta, which we all know in 2D, if you throw
your cell with TGF-beta, they undergo EMT.
But you can see that at soft condition, they actually do not undergo EMT
under
TGF-beta treatment. It's really a combination of the stiffness
cooperate with the TGF-beta to drive this program.
So that basically led us to ask the question, what does
the stiffness do to the EMT program?
As you all know, the EMT program orchestrated
by a group of transcription factor, including the Snail, the Zeb,
and the Twist transcription factor.
So we went on to show that indeed, one of this transcription
factor, Twist1, we have been working on, is actually responsive to
stiffness-induced EMT and invasion.
As you can see, if we remove Twist in this culture we did in
human mouse and PDX, they all block the
stiffness-induced EMT, as you can see in both the
marker or the quantification.
And the way it works mechanistically is that you can see this
is human Twist, this is mouse Twist.
The protein level do not change. But when you increase
stiffness, you see this drastic translocation from the
cytosol to the nucleus of the Twist transcription factor.
That explains why, at a soft stiffness, it cannot
induce EMT.
And what really, I think,
quite
interesting to us is, at that time, we were trying to publish this, and
Yap is reported to be responsive to
stiffness. So we did a side-by-side comparison.
So this is the experiment. We
basically changed the
acting cytoskeleton, because Yap is known to be sensitive
to cytoskeleton change or die in stiff condition.
So we make the cell stretch as much as it like, or we can
do micropatterning, control the size of the cell, basically control the
actin cytoskeleton stretching. What you can see is
Yap. This is co-staining Yap. You can see that
instead of being the nucleus in a stretched condition, they started
to become cytosolic, because you can see the nucleus here.
So they come into the cytosol. But if you look at
Twist, you can see that Twist is a nuclear protein, do not
respond to the cytoskeleton change.
So this really tells us that in our cells, there are different type
of sensing system that responds to changes in a
different way and actually very specifically drives
specific transcription response.
So that really drive us to start looking at, so
then what does
the stiffness actually drive Twist nuclear
translocation? Through a lot of work, I'm just going to summarize, we
end up identify a protein,
G3BP2, as a cytoplasmic anchor of Twist1.
In the soft condition, this anchoring mechanism prevent
Twist1 to anchor into the nucleus.
When you have a stiff condition, Twist is modified, which will
show you how that actually dissociate from
G3BP2 drive Twist nuclear translocation.
So I'm only going to show--
Okay. So you can see here,
this is looking at proximity ligation, basically looking at the
endogenous Twist and G3BP2 interaction at a soft
versus stiff condition. You can see clearly without even
quantification that this interaction is specific to the soft
condition at the cytosol and it disappear when you increase
stiffness. And
what really regulate this is actually this little domain we
identified on Twist that is required for G3BP2
binding. On this motif, there's a tyrosine residue.
It's actually-You can see when we raise the antibody
against this tyrosine, it shows specific activation at a high
stiffness, but not in the low stiffness.
And that actually controls Twist binding to G3BP2.
We end up identifying the kinase that drive this phosphorylation event
to be the
Src family kinase Lin. You can see that Lin is
uniquely activated at high stiffness, but not in the low stiffness.
In contrast, Src kinase is not regulated.
When we use a Lin inhibitor, we can block this
Twist activation. We can block Twist nuclear
translocation at high stiffness.
We can also block invasion. This is just a control
to show the inhibitor is specific.
So when we look at this, we thought, hmm, so that suggests
there's a
specific sensor that activate Lin, phosphorylate
Twist, allow it to enter into the nucleus to drive EMT.
Then what are the sensors? We still don't know, actually.
So, I'm not going to talk about Ephrin A2.
This is a published work. If you're interested, you could look at it.
But what we decided to do is to perform a
tyrosine kinase inhibitor screen, because at that time, we know Lin is a
tyrosine kinase. We're hoping we can find other kinases that
may regulate Lin activation.
But during that screen, we actually found something quite surprising.
So in that library, we have two tyrosine kinase
inhibitor that against the JAK family kinase.
So JAK family kinase or the JAK-STAT signaling kinase
have four members, JAK1, 2, 3, and TYK2.
And JAK3 is actually only expressed in the blood
cells, but JAK1, 2, and TYK2 are widely expressed in
epithelium. You can see this inhibitor that target
JAK1, 2, and TYK2 show very
surprisingly massive invasion at soft condition when we
treat it with the inhibitor. But this inhibitor only target
JAK1 and 2 have no phenotype in terms of invasion, which
surprised us. This suggests that something about the TYK2
inhibition that drives tumor invasion.
So I just mentioned JAK family kinase have four
members. The way it usually works is downstream of
the interferon or interleukin receptor.
TYK2 binds to interferon R1 heterodimer with a
JAK1 or JAK2 to transmit to the STAT signal.
But I just told you the JAK1/2 inhibitor had no phenotype, but
only in the TYK2 inhibitor show phenotype.
So we decided to look a little more carefully.
So this is a genetic deletion of
TYK2 in the culture.
You can see that control cells, Twist cytosol, Twist
nuclear, non-invasive, invasive.
But when we deleted TYK2, you can see at a soft condition,
Twist enters into the nucleus and the culture become highly
invasive. Phenocopy the inhibitor phenotype.
And this is the quantification. You can see this quite
dramatic increase of invasion. You can also see by
looking at the EMT marker, there's an increase of
mesenchymal differentiation.
So we immediately start looking at TYK2 kinase activity.
You can see with the increase of stiffness
when we immunoprecipitated TYK2, we see the decrease of
TYK2 kinase activity, suggesting the inactivation of
the kinase in response to increase of stiffness.
And actually, there are two specific TYK2 inhibitor.
One of them, this is the BMS inhibitor, actually already went
into clinic for psoriasis treatment, and this one
actually is in phase three trial. So those are allosteric
inhibitor of TYK2 that do not touch any other JAK family
kinase. So we did side-by-side comparison with the
AZD1482, which is a JAK1/2 specific
inhibitor. As you can see, this is only a three-day treatment.
You can see that these two inhibitor both
induced organoid invasion at soft condition.
At a stiff condition, everybody is invading, so there's no
difference. You can see in this quantification, the
JAK1/2 inhibitor have no phenotype, but the TYK2 inhibitor
drive invasion, both of them. So that becomes quite
concerning. Somehow, there's
an unknown role of TYK2 in the epithelial cell.
So we decided to look further to validate our
finding in patient-derived xenografts.
So in collaboration with Helen Piwnica-Worms' group, she have
established many of the triple negative PDX.
We isolated PDX organoids from fresh
isolated tumor cells and put them on a gradient
of stiffness. As you can see that the
PDX organoid do not behave as
uniformly as cell line derived organoid.
But you can still see that when we increase stiffness, the
cells start to invade more in the culture.
This is the black bars, the quantification of the PDX
model responsive to stiffness. You can still see this increase of
stiffness, though it's much more heterogeneous.
But you can see we don't even need quantification.
When we treat it with the TYK2 inhibitor for five days, there's
drastic increase of invasion, and this is actually even
dose dependent. You can see when we increase the dose, we see a further
invasion. And this is the biochemical validation.
As I told you, the TYK2 is inactivated in response to increase
of stiffness. When we treat it with the TYK2 inhibitor, you see
a complete inactivation of the
kinase.And you may ask, or
maybe TYK2 is some sort of cell junction
protector. It just protects cell junction.
So to show that TYK2 actually function upstream of Twist 1 in
this mechanotransduction pathway, we deleted
Twist in the system. You can see that at soft condition,
cells start to invade when we deleted TYK2.
But when we double delete Twist, no matter soft and stiff, you basically
can block the stiffness-induced invasive phenotype,
suggesting that TYK2 actually function upstream to
transmit the signal to Twist.
And you're probably going to ask me, how?
We all know how JAK-STAT works. JAK is dimerized and
activate phosphorylation-stat signaling.
We thought so too, so we checked really carefully.
So first thing we did, which I already showed you, is to inhibit JAK1 or
JAK2. We have no phenotype on invasion.
It definitely--
And then we also used blocking
antibody against interferon receptor because this is
interferon-based signaling that transmit to the TYK2 and
JAK1 in memory epithelial cells. We also
stimulated with interferon alpha and beta.
What you can see is we could not see any phenotype in terms of the
invasion. They all behave like what they always behave as the
control cells.
Then we also used inhibitor. I'm not going to show you here.
They're all negative data. We
directly inhibit STAT,
and we also do not show any phenotype in terms of
invasion, which you probably already predicted since the JAK
kinase inhibition did not show phenotype.
We also genetically removed interferon R2, which
is the receptor that binds to the JAK1 in the signaling
system. There's also no phenotype.
The only one that gave us phenotype is-- oh, sorry,
is actually when we genetically removed interferon R1,
because this is the receptor that anchor TYK2 on the cell membrane,
and this anchoring mechanism is important for JAK family
kinase to be active because otherwise they fall off membrane.
This firm domain interaction is essential.
You can see this deletion actually phenotypic copy with
TYK2 deletion phenotype that increase invasion at a
soft condition.
So then we decided to say, "Oh, is this really
involved in this? Somehow TYK2 is inactivated because of
the receptor, the interferon R1." So we started
looking at TYK2 protein at soft versus
stiff condition. You can see the protein level do not change in response to
stiffness, no matter it's mouse or human.
But when we immunostain TYK2, now you can see in the
soft condition, TYK2 is on the membrane as is supposed to be
because it's always on the membrane.
All JAK family kinase always made and bind to the receptor
localized on the membrane. However, when we increase stiffness, we see
this diffused TYK2 staining in the cytosol.
This is not because of cell under EMT.
They lose junction because if we block EMT using the inhibitor,
we still see this diffuse of TYK2 in response
to change of stiffness, suggesting this is on the top of the
sensing mechanism, not a consequence of EMT.
And as you probably expected now, when we immunoprecipitated
TYK2 from the soft versus stiff condition, we see that this
interaction with interferon R1 is disrupted when we
increase stiffness. This is regardless of the kinase is active or not.
This is active mutant kinase still can no longer bind to
interferon R1. That's when we deleted interferon R1,
you can actually see, it's easier to see in the line graph,
this membrane localization of TYK2 is lost at
soft condition.
So basically, the interferon anchoring TYK2 is the
mechanism in response to stiffness.
When you increase it, somehow they dissociate and TYK2 fall off
the membrane, becoming activated to function as a
metastasis suppressor. We went on to look at TYK2
localization in human breast cancer.
This is a tissue microarray looking at normal breast
tissue versus breast cancer. It's actually,
you can see TYK2 is on the membrane.
We co-stain with E-cadherin, but this localization is
lost in all invasive breast cancer.
You see this very diffused cytosolic TYK2 staining.
If I draw the line graph, you can see it clearly, this membrane
localization TYK2 become diminished.
You actually don't even need to look at my data.
If you go to Human Protein Atlas and look at their human breast cancer data,
it exactly look like this. And so basically,
we decided to check to try to understand
whether TYK2 really have a metastasis suppression function.
And we have done
knock down TYK2 in tumor cells in both cell line derived,
also PDX derived, but I'm only going to show you one set of
data. This is by implanting that PDX
model. We have two. This is one of them into the
immunodeficient mice, let the tumor form, and then we
treated with TYK2 inhibitor. This is oral treatment,
just like what a psoriasis patient receive for five weeks.
And then we harvested the cell. You can see that the primary tumor,
they do not change the primary tumor weight.
However, you can see this drastic increase of dissemination because our
PDX are labeled with GFP. You see a much more lung nodule
present when-After five weeks treatment of this TIG2
inhibitor, you can also see there's much more nuclear
Twist1 present in those primary tumors after
treatment.
So I don't have time to tell you how TIG2
inhibited Twist function. What we found is TIG2 interferes
actually Afrin
A2 and Lin's interaction to inhibit Twist
phosphorylation and itself to stimulate, to inhibit
Twist nuclear translocation. But I think the take-home
message is really that our cells seem to have very
unique mechano-- We still don't know what exactly is the mechano sensor,
but they do seem to present very unique mechano sensing
mechanism. They can interpret the stiffness of the cell, and they
can actually generate very unique transcription
response, in this case is EMT and invasion.
This data really suggests that the physical property of the
extracellular matrix actually play a quite important role in a
more normal breast tumor. When you have
a normal
stiffness, there's actually a metastasis suppression function of this
physical cue from the ECM in terms of
modifying metastasis. So in the end, I just want to
hope that I also try to convince you that mechanical
force is actually one of the major regulator of this
epithelial mesenchymal plasticity and a regulator of the
metastasis process. If you want to know a little more in detail
of the biochemistry and cell biology, I have one postdoc who's going to
give a mini talk, and a graduate student who's present a poster of another
phosphatase we identified in this mechano transaction pathway.
In the end, I just want to thank all the people who have done this work
and this TIG2 work. Initially, Spencer and Laurent
actually set up the entire system to study this
EMT and mechano regulation, and Hanna and Jiamin are the two
driving force of the TIG2 work. We also
collaborated with bioengineers, like Adam Ankner,
to build different material, trying to study this, and many people have
helped us along the way. Thank you so much.
Yes.
Hi. Great talk. So your data clearly showed that the
stiffness alone can strongly affect the phenotype
of cells, tumor cells, right? So that-
Maybe I shouldn't-- So I said I use triple negative sensor,
so the cell already have probably some kind of
autocrine-
Mm-hmm
... loop that drive EMT gene expression.
Yes.
So they already have the
transcription turned on.
Yeah.
Your talk makes me wonder how-
Yeah
... culturing cells in a plastic dish would affect their phenotype because
when we do-
Yeah
... in vitro experiments, we generally use plastic dishes, which is much stiffer
than actual tissues, right?
Yeah.
So have you looked at the gene expression, protein expression in the
cells culture in the plastic dish?
Yeah.
And did they look like the cells-
Yeah
... culture in stiff?
Yeah. I think now there's enough gene expression
data being uploaded into GEOD. You can see the 2D, 3D
difference is quite significant.
And
at least in the Petri dish, it really twists nuclear for
sure, the EMT, because all this
gene, EMT gene, that's how it was originally by triple ne--
has this. So there's definitely a major
difference in terms of the specific thing we're looking at.
It's actually very difficult. So when we do many of the gene manipulation,
because we also do all the infection in 2D, right?
The cell actually do not tolerate so well.
Because they are in 2D, you want to shut down the gene
that's what they're supposed to turn on.
We actually quickly usually
inactivate the gene and then put them on 3D right away.
Okay.
Yeah. We also never passage our cell long.
All the PDX work, they never touched plastic dish
because they immediately dedifferentiate. Yeah.
Makes sense. Yeah. Thank you.
Yeah.
Hi. It was wonderful-
Thank you
... hearing you talk. I actually have two questions.
Yeah.
Just out of curiosity, I want to know, you have mainly focused in TNBC over here.
What are your thoughts
on doing similar work on lobular?
Would you have any comments on that about-
Sorry, can you say
doing in a lobular?
Yeah, invasive lobular.
Yeah. So lobular is very unique, right?
The 80% or 90% of lobular breast cancer already lost
E-cadherin.
Exactly.
So they present a much more EMT, already sort of
EMT phenotype.
Yes.
But I haven't done any lobular
work in the 3D. I'm actually wondering if you're culturing them in
3D, what they look like.
Yeah. Especially with lobular organoids, because I
think it would be really interesting to-
Yeah
... see what's going on over there.
Yeah. I don't actually know what are the lobular line.
We have a PDX, I think it was lobular, one or two of
them, but I don't have a line that is
lobular.
Yeah.
Okay. I think I'll talk to you once we have done.
Yeah. Definitely happy to. Yeah.
Yeah. And I think I have a technical question over here.
Yeah
So I was just looking at your data, and I just realized that I do see some
kind of
a little bit of inconsistency in your housekeeping
gene, GAPDH.
Mm-hmm.
To be honest, I have seen similar things when I do my
studies, which I'm going to explain you probably after this.
Sorry, which you mean inconsistent? The loading is not even, you mean?
Yeah, that's what it seems like.
Sure.
But then I always believe that whoever is loading and when we are presenting the
data, we always
Like we are loading equal amount, but still there is some inconsistency.
Very good observation.
Yeah.
You know why?
Because I have been seeing the same thing, actually.
Yeah.
Which is why I was like-
... do you know why is that happening?
Okay. This is actually something, I don't know, people who work on 3D, I don't know
how many to do biochemistry, would know that because of the matrix
carryover, when you harvest organoid, there's always a
matrix gel there, right? So your OD in protein level is
never even. This is actually extremely difficult, especially
when you do IP, the input. Sometimes we even
first run a gel,
run the GAPDH, and then go back to re-quantify, to
redo. But especially in the soft condition, the
organoids has more carryover than when they invade it.
So you sometimes will see this
technical issue that is really actually very hard to solve.
We try to do mass spec. There's a lot of matrix gel carryover issue
also. I wish someone has better way of doing it.
We actually haven't been able to overcome this technical
challenge. Yeah.
Right.
But good observation. Yeah.
Thank you.
I can show you what we do maybe after, like trying to
get it more even. But it's not.
Yeah. Let's talk after this because I would like to have some inputs about-
Yeah.
Yeah. Okay.
Sure. We're happy to share our protocol. Yeah.
Is it possible to have any kind of kinetic understanding of what
taking place? And if you do have kinetic, is it possible-
Yeah
... to have some frequency modulation and see?
Yeah. So I don't know you mean time point
or you mean...
Just
like
with
mechanical stress, sometimes there's a frequency modulation you can see.
Oh. So I guess-
Is that possible?
Yeah. So
I guess the ECMs is a little different.
These are mechanical engineers, then
stretching, there's frequency, when people
study heart muscle and that type
of mechanic. But there's time point, right? When does this happen?
So we have a UV-based gel that we can shed UV
light to stiffen it. And we have a knocking a little twist.
We're trying to do time lapse, but those gels are really hard to work
with when they're at 200 Pascal. They really...
So we don't know. It seemed to be quite quickly.
I would say definitely within 24 hours, the sensing mechanism
twists and enters very fast, feels like no additional
transcription required.
Great.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Hi.
Nice one.
So I work on GBM. I'm in Dr. Adam Englander's lab.
So I was wondering that you showed mechanisms of invasion and something
that I want to relate back is to GBM,
mechanisms of EMT and stuff. But in GBM specifically, we don't see
metastasis, but there is invasion.
Mm-hmm.
So I was wondering how applicable or how broad the
mechanism of Z twist or the Jack stat pathway that you showed might be
applicable to other cancers where there is similar invasive fronts
and stuff like that, because it's again, interaction with the
microenvironment.
Yeah. So we haven't really ventured out.
This took us a long time to do the PDX work.
One thing you could do, which we tried to do, you can look in the
human protein atlas to look at TIG2 expression
compared normal versus tumor. I
think we saw in a couple, but they're all epithelial tumor, this type of
redistribution.
Okay.
But we haven't actually done work on them.
Because there's almost no publication on TIG2 in epithelial
tissue. It's almost exclusively studied in immune cell.
There was one paper from a clinical work.
They said TIG2 level dropped. They meant dropped in tumors,
but they meant dropped is because it's cytoplasmic look like
it's less, but it's actually just much more
cytoplasmic. Yeah. But I haven't tried.
Okay.
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
Hi, Patrick from Genentech.
Yeah.
I just have a question regarding your TIG2 inhibitor.
It seems that it's actually locking the cell in an E-cadherin low
twist, one high cells. How do you reconcile the increase in
metastasis with the
known observation about the MET where the cells
actually need to restore their epithelial characteristics back in
order to actually be able to form overt metastasis in the
lungs?
Oh, yeah. But this is not the model we are
counting is really the dissemination event because this is only four
weeks.
So what you've quantified is actually-
And also those are line derived.
So
you're saying that they should revert-
Yeah
... in to grow.
Yeah, based on Andrew Ewald, Angela Nieto's group,
they showed that actually epithelial reconversion is
required for efficient metastatic dissemination.
Yeah. We also
reported using-
Yeah. So I'm guessing-
This many years ago. Yeah. So I don't know in terms of
when we use GFP label, we're really just looking at the dissemination
event at this moment.
We haven't been looking so deep into the regrowth.
They're not big tumors in the lung.
I guess. Okay.
They're just GFP labeled dots.
I see. Yeah.
Because it's very quick, right? This is just treat for three to
five weeks and immediately looking at the dissemination event.
Yeah.
I don't know, in this type of model, line derived model,
is that critical, this reversion.
When we originally, we actually one of the first group reported in a
cancer cell paper using genetical model, there is a true epithelium.
We used the skin model and then did the twist turn on/off with
ARO versus dox.
But those are true epithelium to start.
But this is a-
... line derived or PDX derived.
I see.
I don't think they fully recapitulate that reversion event.
I see. And just following up on the previous questions-
Yeah
... about the lobular carcinoma.
Yeah.
Actually, the majority of the lines are ER positive, not triple negative.
Oh, yeah. You're right. So they're ER positive.
Yeah.
But they actually, I don't know if there's human lines of them.
There are, yeah. Like some-
There are
... 34 MDA-MB-134.
Oh, okay. Good to know.
So we can discuss, yeah.
Oh, yeah. Thank you.
Thank you.
All right. Thank you so much.
Okay.
Thank you so much the organizers, and thank you so much guys for staying.
So we're going to get a bit more fundamental here.
And today, I'm going to talk to you about how cues from the microenvironment can
have implications for diagnostics and therapeutic
efficacy.
So I always like to start by defining what I'm going to talk about today.
I have no disclosures.
So from a fundamental perspective, basic science discoveries have
allowed us to form a pipeline for,
I would say, options for druggable targets for therapeutic options.
By simply understanding what genes and molecules
differentiate cancer cells from their normal counterparts,
by understanding how cancer cells interact with other cell types such as immune
cells, have given us a slew of targeted therapies as well
as immunotherapies, and not only restricted to the
genetic or molecular subtypes, but understand if cancer cells have
different metabolic or physical properties aid in our
tools in terms of diagnostics, namely underpinning the
methodologies behind MRI, PET, and ultrasound.
But in spite of all of this progress, the reality is that we don't have durable
therapies for all patients, for all types of cancers.
And the question becomes then, how could we then enhance either existing
therapeutics or derive new ones?
So I've defined in terms of our pipelines to drive cancer discovery
drugs. But the question then now comes down into what aspects
about the microenvironment may be important in regulating these processes.
So in this schematic I'm showing you here, histology is
progressing from skin epithelium all the way to malignant transformation,
and there are two things by eye that one could appreciate.
If one looks at the morphology, meaning size and shape of
the skin cells, as a function from normal to
malignancy, we see that there are differences in these sizes.
A second observation is simply if we look at this delineation between epithelium
and connective tissues, namely a basement membrane, we see
alterations as well at different length scales in terms of the architectural.
So these are architectural biophysical cues that are changed as a function of
malignancy.
Now if we do one other step by using the appropriate mechanical
mapping methodologies, one can also measure
changes in mechanical properties at the cell scale, at the tissue scale.
And the question now becomes how does this then influence our ability to
understand why do cancers progress?
And more importantly, how could we treat them?
So in the last, I guess maybe two decades or so, this field of cancer
mechanobiology has emerged, and we've already heard some excellent talks
highlighting some of the techniques and methodologies used to try
to understand or to harness this understanding of
mechanotransduction.
So today I'm going to talk to you in terms of how do cells sense forces.
How does that then imply there are changes in terms of cell fate decisions?
I'm going to speak a bit about how do we detect these changes
directly in either preclinical models or directly in
patients right now. And as discussion points at the end of
my talk, I hope we could get a discussion about how could we then use this as
possible druggable targets. Make sense so far? Okay, good.
So mechanotransduction, we've already heard marvelous talks about the ability of
cells using different types of integrins, receptor tyrosine
kinases, to be able to then drive cell fate decisions all the way down to the
nucleus with transcription factors.
But I still need to define to you what these mechanical inputs are.
So we've heard a lot that tissues, cells are biological tissues are
viscoelastic. So what does that mean?
As I play this cartoon, this is a Oobleck fluid.
Simply, you can mix this with cornstarch and water, and I want you to now
think of this fingers being a cell interrogating its environment.
We could be an extracellular matrix environment. It could be other cell types.
And more importantly, at the four scale, length scale, you can see that the
material properties are different.
It either becomes more solid-like versus liquid-like.
If we then put this into a formula, it simply tells us that we can
then quantify these mechanical properties by the storage or
loss modulus. You may have heard of Young's modulus, which is a variant of this
elastic modulus, and this dissipative event, which is known as
this loss modulus.
Okay?
Good.
And you may have known in terms of just following this field, as I said, this is
over the course of two decades, that if we then culture cells on
substrates that are stiffer versus softer, we see
differences in morphology. Here I'm simply showing human melanoma cell
lines. This has been shown for many different types of cell lines, cancers, and so
forth. And you can see that there's a regular architecture in terms of its actin
cytoskeleton,
vinculin, which is a focal adhesion protein, and you can see differences in nuclear
sizes.
And then if now we look into the literature, many groups have shown that either
by PSO channel, as a ion channel, we talked
about RTK integrins, et cetera, that these cues can
then elucidate downstream signaling events all the way to transcription
factors that then govern the cell's ability to migrate, to die,
to be able to evade immune evasion, and so
forth.So in terms of therapeutic
efficacy, it's also been shown
that YAP translocation is influenced by the cell's ability
to sense stiff versus soft substrates.
Here we see cytoplasmic YAP on soft substrates, whereas a more nuclear
localization, and this also influences a cell fate decision.
If then you use, in this case, this is human melanoma cell lines,
BRAF inhibition, you also see there's a differential regulation where cells
cultured on soft substrates have more resistance to
therapeutics than if they were cultured on soft substrates.
So all in all, this is just now setting a baseline of what we've learned in the
last two decades.
So fundamentally, we decided to ask a few questions.
If cells are indeed responding to viscoelastic cues,
at the fundamental level, does a cell sense each of these cues independently?
Is it cooperative? Is there regime dependence?
And more importantly, what machinery is a cell using to be able to do
this type of cell sensing? And then how would it then influence cell fate
decisions? So I'm going to talk to you about unpublished data, it's currently under
review, of our ability to try to get to this fundamental question.
So what did we do? We used biomimetic gels where we could
then modulate and tailor each of these individual components.
So as a reminder, we're able to modulate either loss modulus or the
elastic or loss moduli, and I'm going to show you just for a few
conditions here. So we have something that's extremely stiff, so 18
kilopascals, almost 20-fold stiffer than a soft
substrate. And then I'm going to talk to you about just adding a very small
amount of the loss modulus. And just to put things in numbers, this is less
than 1% change of the overall magnitude of the complex
modulus. Make sense so far? Good. So what did we find?
As a reminder, stiff versus soft, you see differences in
phenotypes. But just by adding a very small amount of this loss
modulus, 160 pascals to one kilopascals as shown
here, you see that the cells begin to phenocopy what it sees on a stiff
substrate.
But that's just morphology. What about these other factors that then influence
signaling?
Going back to our idea of drug efficacy, as a reminder,
soft substrates, these cells are more susceptible to treatment, but
once they're primed on these more viscous substrates, again, the
G prime remains the same. We see that it starts to phenocopy
what is seen on a purely stiff substrate.
Now, this is where it starts to get interesting. Why are we seeing these changes?
So let me walk you through how we quantify these effects.
What you're seeing here is a normalization factor where we stain for an
epigenetic marker methylation site normalized to the heterochromatin
that's in each of these nuclei, and the heat maps simply tell you as a
function of white to blue, meaning that more yellow it is,
it's a higher increase. And what we see that even for soft versus
stiff primed cells, that there's an enhancement in terms of this
epigenetic remodeling. That's also even more enhanced for cells when
you add that small amount of the loss modulus.
Now, the question we had is, what's the timing of this? How long?
Because cells can
be exposed to very acute
mechanical priming, versus cells can be within a microenvironment over the course
of several days, weeks, and so forth, as it would be in a tumor microenvironment.
So suffice to say, we see this remodeling as early as two days of conditioning,
which then becomes much more pronounced as we go as a function
of days cultured in these environments.
But the question we had is simply, did we just luck out?
Was this just a Goldilocks effect?
Meaning that the cells just happen to think it's on a soft
substrate. Is this iterative? Meaning if we go in between
50, 100, and 180 pascals, which you see here, we see that there's a progressive
loss, a progressive enhancement of this epigenetic
remodeling.
So what happens in terms of this YAP localization?
As a reminder, YAP is localized to the nucleus when
primed on stiff substrates. It becomes cytoplasmic when it's on a soft
substrate, and then it starts to move back to the nucleus upon this
viscous priming.
This also shows this cumulative event when we go from zero
pascals all the way up to 160 pascals.
So one of the questions is why are we seeing this and why do we see these time
differences?
So we need to ask more fundamental questions of what is really being changed,
on the fundamental level, both on a cell mechanical phenotype as
well as in terms of a transcriptomic analysis.
So first, we used this high-throughput system where simply we
flow these cells under given fluid shear stress, and then it
allows us to quantify the deformation under an applied stress, and you
can see that if it's stiff primed, that these cells actually are
less deformable than when they're primed on soft substrates, but then they
began to go back to what you see on a stiff
primed substrate as you add in this additive
loss moduli.
More importantly, the stiffness of these cells also phenocopy.
So I've shown you at least from the morphological perspective, from some
aspects of the YAP, but let's try to get a handle of why is this happening.
So we did some transcriptomic analysis, and let me explain what was done here.
We simply asked what is common to stiff and viscous
primed cells that are differentially regulated to what is found in the soft
primed cells. And to no surprise to you guys, we see some
cytoskeleton proteins that are differentially regulated, but we were surprised to
see that actually tubulins were much more differentially
regulated than, say, actin-like cytoskeleton proteins.
Okay?And vinculin was also differentially regulated.
If we feed this now into pathway analysis, we also see that cell
cycle, which I'm happy to discuss about later on, and something that
Sanjay touched on in terms of metabolism is also differentially regulated,
but that's something I'd like to keep for discussion points.
So based on this information now, we decide to then interrogate the
cytoskeleton proteins in terms of the cell's ability to transduce what it's
sensing at the focal adhesion stage, all the way to the nucleus to drive this
translocation of Yap.
So as a reminder, the architecture of the cell is comprised of its biggest
organelle, which is the nucleus, which is coupled via cytoskeleton
proteins, either intermediate filaments, microtubules, actin, cytoskeleton
proteins, to focal adhesions to be able to sense this extracellular matrix.
So using a computational model, we model this interaction as if it were
simply a combinatorial dash spring
sort of mechanism, treating each of these components as if it's a
viscoelastic unit.
What these curves simply state is if it is that we then
extend a strain on each of these components, you see that as a
function of more strain, which is now mimicking this loss modulus, then
we see that there's a huge reorganization in nuclear
envelope, which we believe is facilitating this reprogramming that we're
seeing with this epigenetic reprogramming.
So what happens then if we-- I'm going to just show you data
for if we
interrogate or modify
the microtubules. So as a reminder, this is the morphology on
stiff versus soft. We see that it starts to phenocopy on viscous.
But if we then mitigate microtubules using nocodazole, in this
case, we see that the viscous prime cells now start
to behave as if they were soft primed.
What happens in this case, again, blebbistatin now will treat actin
cytoskeleton via upstream myosin IIA inhibition.
We see that there's a loss of this epigenetic reprogramming compared to the
viscous vehicle control, and this is quantified more rigorously
here in these graphs.
So in sum here, what we're observing is that
there is indeed a sensing that's transduced via the
actin cytoskeleton and the microtubules all the way to the nuclear envelope,
and this is what is then driving this epigenetic
reprogramming that we see at day seven.
In terms of Yap localization, we also see that there's a loss of the
nuclear Yap localization as compared to viscous
control as quantified here in these graphs.
So I've talked about the coupling that these cells have in terms of the focal
adhesions via the cytoskeleton elements, via the nuclear envelope
that drives phenotypic changes. But the question is, from the
perspective of what does a cell do when it has to escape and
migrate to form metastasis, are these then changed?
So previously, we have been using a zebrafish model to be
able to look at these early extravasation events.
One aspect of human disease is that cells that
originate from a given primary tumor often show a non-random
selection.
And there are cell lines, human cell lines, these are
MDA-MB-231s, these are triple negative breast cancer cell lines,
that when injected into mice, preferentially home to either the brain of the
mice versus that of the bone marrow of the mice.
And we've shown previously that if you take these same cells and inject them
directly into the larval zebrafish, where we have
organ analogs for the brain,
what defines a zebrafish brain is comparable to what defines a mammalian
brain, and this transient organ known as the cardiovascular
plexus. In short, what we found is the cells that home to the brain of the
mice also home to the brain of the zebrafish, and more
importantly, the
cells that home to the bone marrow of the mice also home to this
transient bone marrow niche in the zebrafish.
So then ask this question, based on using the system, do we then see
differences in extravasation?
And I'm just showing you data for the viscous untreated versus viscous
non-treated. So let me orient you in terms of this micrograph.
This is a larval zebrafish. The blood vessels are now in grayscale.
This is its head, brain, as shown as the inset.
Now, the magenta cells are cells that have been primed for seven
days on this viscous. And we see that there's a distribution that
some
animals show a colonization of both brain and CVP, as shown
here, and then we have some fish that only have brain metastases
versus bone marrow niche metastases.
But when we then compare to cells that were primed
and nocodazole, where the microtubules are now disrupted, we see
that there's a loss of this ability to go to the brain with
an increase of the cell's ability to go to this bone marrow niche.
And I'm happy to discuss to you what types of transcriptomic changes
modulated to be able to facilitate this, I
would say, loss of colonization of the brain.
So today, I hope that I've convinced you in terms of we need to get to a more
granular understanding of how cells sense differences
between elastic and loss moduli. It cannot be simply that we
compare stiff versus soft, because in some regimes, a cell could
phenocopy what it merely sees on a purely stiff substrate if it
is that is given correct force inputs.
These indeed change in terms of, at least at the transcript level, to
differences in Yap nuclearization.
I didn't show you microfluidic devices where we see differences in confined
migration. And then in turn, we see this huge
chromatin reorganization that drives epigenetic
remodeling. The model system and some data that I haven't
shown you also focus on this coupling between focal adhesions all the way to the
nucleus. And more importantly, when we then look in our preclinical
zebrafish model, we're able to see that this indeed affects the cell's ability to
colonize different organs.So for the last minute, I'm going to talk to you
about how do we then do this in vivo.
So I mentioned that it's important to understand why, how do cell
sense this, and in turn, how does it then govern cell fate decisions?
But more importantly, we need to be able to measure this directly, either in our
preclinical models, as many of the previous speakers are in
organoids or so forth, all the way up to human patients.
And what my group has done in the last, I guess,
14 years now, is develop tools to be able to do so.
So what you're looking at here is repurposed optical tweezers, where we use
near-infrared light. We're able to focus that near-infrared light directly into
the living animal, and by inferring from the deflection based on our applied
forces, we can then pull out the mechanical properties that I mentioned in terms of
G prime and G double prime.
More recently, we have then coupled this with Brillouin microscopy, which is based
on a non-invasive scattering, meaning that light photons interact
with phonons within tissues, and by then understanding these shifts, we
can also pull out mechanical properties directly from these living
animals.
But the question is, how do we then relate this to humans?
And I'm here to tell you that
one of the biggest pushes in the field right now is how do we link our measurements
at the pico scale all the way to these macro scale measurements, which are
done right now in human patients using magnetic resonance
elastography, where you use sound waves to then
travel within brain tissue. It's already in clinical trials for
studying therapy responses in liver cancers.
And the idea now is to be able to then harness this information to
understand why some tumors respond versus why some don't.
So
I'd like to thank the people who did the work.
I tried to have their names, but Kan is the postdoc.
She's the first author on the work that I presented today.
She's been assisted by Patricia. Norbert is the one who-- Sorry, Woongyoung, who
goes by Norbert, he's the one who has done most of the measurements in terms
of the mechanical, and I didn't talk about metabolic mapping directly
in zebrafish. I'd like to thank my funding sources.
I'd like to thank you guys for staying.
I'd like to thank my speakers, and hopefully, you have some questions.
So thank you.
Thank you for that really interesting talk. I just had a question.
I was really interested in the changes you see with the histone
3 lysine 9 trimethylation. Do you
see any other chromatin modifications that are being
altered in this way? Like, are there repressive chromatin marks-
Yes
... that are also changing?
So that's an excellent point in terms of, is it simply either
just this methylation factor or is it acetylation factors and so forth?
And the short answer is there are other,
so we'll have a much more complete story. But yes, you're correct.
Oh.
Okay.
Very interesting. Thank you.
So just to clarify, we believe it's a full chromatin remodeling that's
taking place. So it's not limited to one methylation factor.
I see. Yeah, and the polycomb repressive complex
transcriptional changes you were seeing, I think
that might indicate you have H3K27me3 modifications.
I think that you're spot on.
Yeah.
And good eye.
Thank you.
Thank you. Hi. Yes?
Thank you so much for this actually elegant and detailed work when it comes
to Hippo-Yap pathway, especially Yap.
Uh-huh.
And then it looks like that the Yap is operating in context-dependent manner.
Yes.
Because actually, what we are showing in melanoma
or skin cancer cells, which actually contradict, but actually
breast cancers or breast, actually, the tissue is showing different pattern.
But you are showing here is a stiff Yap is in nuclei,
and then the previous, actually, speaker talked about it is stiff
Yap is in the cytoplasm. Am I correct on that one?
So I think, let me see if I could back up, and I apologize if I didn't.
I've sped through this.
So you're very right in the sense that this is context dependent.
And we
have a very specific regime, so we're looking at 18
kilopascals versus one kilopascals, and then a range from zero to
160 pascals for the loss modulus.
But we need to look at it from the perspective of what the forces
are being sensed at the focal adhesion level. Right?
And in that regime that we're in, that's when the cells phenocopy it.
So for breast cancer cells, triple-negative breast cancer cells, we
saw also this trans-Yap localization, but
albeit at 100
pascals, whereas the melanomas showed it as early as 50 pascals.
But if you were then to tune to, say, to go to five kilopascals
as your G prime, your storage modulus, you would then have to find the
equivalent of what that drag force is needed to be able
to drive this cumulative force that these cells sense to phenocopy
what a stiff-only substrate. So in terms of context dependent, I don't
want you to look at absolute values.
I want you to look at it from the perspective of what forces are being
felt in cumulative dissipative versus storage, and if
that is then able to phenocopy what the force distribution
would be on a purely stiff substrate. Okay?
I understand that, however, and then because Yap, actually, nuclear localization
is really dynamic.
Yeah.
Have you looked at the kinetics of it?
Because also look at the upstream signaling-
Yeah
... because there are several factors in the upstream signaling-
You are 100%
... that regulate Yap.
You are 100% correct. We think that Yap is so far downstream to
what we're seeing, that it's a readout to say that
transcription factors may be affected, but we do think it only has to do with
the chromatin remodeling. So it's a purely look in terms of
binding
sites available. So that's what we think it is.
We do not think for a second that Yap per se is
sensing this. We think it's just
due to the fact of the global reprogramming of the nuclear
envelope.
Okay?
Okay. Thank you.
No problem. Thank you.
Hello. Hi.
Hi, how are you doing?
I'm Chinna Kurada. I work at Children's Hospital of Los Angeles.
I work with stiffness and also leader cells and follower
cells. But major thing is you clearly mentioned about
the substrate. Okay, by changing the substrate, we can see the
cells.
Right.
I can also see the cells. I have a simple question.
How much time the memory-
Yeah
... is maintained?
So I-
If I change the surface, if I want the cells to further
go for the different culturing. So definitely the
morphology and the module will be changed, and
yeah, it's like how much time the memory will be maintained?
In our case, the earliest time to see that
there's a two-tiered priming, so there's an
acute stage that happens at early as two days, and that's at the focal adhesion
level.
Mm-hmm.
But in order to show this long-range effects to the full reprogramming
nuclear envelope, for the human cells, it takes about seven days.
For we have zebrafish melanomas, it occurs much earlier at five days,
and we think it's just due to the size of the genome. Right.
So there is indeed a conditioning and so forth,
but there is a priming, as you said, that needs to take place,
but the acute effects begin as early as two days.
Thank you for clearing that.
No problem.
Thank you.
No, thanks for the question.
Hi, Kandice.
Jordi.
Beautiful work.
Jordi, how are you doing?
Good.
So,
you mentioned that it's focal adhesions that are-
Yeah
... transducing these changes in the viscosity.
Right.
I wonder if you
have found any division of labor, that different components within the focal
adhesion-
Right
... complex sense elasticity versus viscosity, or really the
whole
system that is
sensing both aspects of mechanics and transducing them.
So Jordi, what we think is going on is, if you're familiar with
Jian's work,
Jian also came from Berkeley. So sorry, Jordi was from Berkeley as well.
And these focal adhesions do this oscillatory behavior to be able
to then feed back to the actin cytoskeleton.
So what we think here is going on is that that
oscillatory behavior, because of the loss modulus as a drag
force, that then cooperatively then links back to the
actin cytoskeleton. So in terms of which components,
we don't think it's sensing one individually.
We think it's purely cooperative at that level.
Now, what I don't know yet is if it's vinculin as a
driver versus paxillin or so forth, because we're collaborating with Ken Yamato,
who, as you know, is the adhesion expert, and we're
trying to see if it's purely vinculin being a mechanosensor,
or is it that the whole focal adhesion complex is affected by this, and
I don't have an answer for that. But the model simply says it's at the focal
adhesions.
And do you know if ion channels may be involved, like phase one?
So in terms of if they're ion channels, I would argue that the
timescale at which we're seeing this, it may be at a more acute
stage, right? So ion channels will probably be-- we're seeing this in
conditioning of two days, right, and ion channels would have to be a little faster,
but that's something we should look into if that may be the symmetry-breaking event
that may then drive this focal adhesion adaptation.
So that's a good point.
Yeah, please.
Really beautiful work.
Just follow up that question about this is through
nuclear envelope-
Yeah
... and rearrange your epigenetics.
Right.
How does that achieve specificity?
Because there still is Yap that moves not-
So-
I don't know, Myc did not move, for example.
We didn't test to see Myc, right? So we're agnostic in terms of
what transcription factors may come out.
I have a postdoc who's obsessed with Yap, right?
So that's why we went with Yap,
to be perfectly honest. But I personally do not think that it's
Yap only that would be affected by this reorganization of a nuclear
envelope. Right. I think that if, for example, we look at Myc or so
forth, that may also show differences in localization.
And that's why when we do the global attack seek stuff, that would become much
more important to really address that.
But I personally don't think it's a Yap-specific thing.
I think that other transcription factors may be affected in terms of their
binding or localization based on the availability of the differences of the
physical properties of the chromatin.
Thank you, guys.
Great.
Yeah.
Thank you so much for coming to the session.